when tinder came out boy was that fun i
was in college that year it was so fun
and now we're in this period where it's
like okay now the rubber's hitting the
road and we're trying to navigate what
it does to the human mind to have that
many people say that they're interested
in you and when i mean that many i mean
like 50 to 100 on one app whether you're
a girl looking for a guy a guy looking
for a girl what does that do to one's
psyche do we know what it does do we
understand it yet or are we still in
this loading screen are we still kind of
just determining where we go from here
zacky boy how are you
i'm good man i'm excited to be back
i know how long has it been a year year
and a half dude yeah a year and a half
wow [ __ ] crazy
yeah really crazy things have happened
since then huh you've moved
were we in pandemic mode
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so okay that
thing hasn't changed oh okay so that's
that's the constant throughout yeah yeah
i've moved i've moved to austin where
everyone seems to be moving
um
you know me joe rogan lex friedman we're
all boys now all the big ones
yeah no i don't
um i was here before them so i can just
that's all i'm gonna say
all right what was that elon musk thing
that you tweeted me the other day
uh so this is an interesting one because
yeah this is an austinite right elon
musk coming here another one of your
boys
yeah another one of my boys he's part of
my posse
uh so
i saw some some blue check mark twitter
guy was like um next time you go car
shopping and
are looking at a shiny new tesla
remember that this [ __ ]
so many people thought was so cool will
not stand up for a single woman in texas
after having just moved his company
there
uh
and then he quotes i would prefer to
stay out of politics so this is this is
elon musk's
uh quote or his tweet
in general i believe government should
rarely impose its will upon the people
and when doing so should aspire to
maximize their cumulative happiness
that said i would prefer to stay out of
politics
so
so the reason i sent that to you is
because that to me is
it's a very interesting one
what is your moral obligation
um to say something
uh even though you don't want to are you
a good person for saying something are
you a bad person for not saying
something um are you even allowed to not
say anything at all
and it it like really messes with my
head right it's like at what level does
saying something matter you know 10 000
followers 50 000 followers what does
that mean
and so that's something that i i like
i would like to talk through because i i
still haven't formulated a
a real opinion on the matter the maddest
thing is that that guy got angry like
from elon that is demonstrably the most
polite balance right tweet ever
you can't you cannot be more balanced
than that it's so nice it's like look i
really don't want the government to get
into people's business if they do get in
people's business they should try and
make them happy that being said i'm not
a politician
okay
look at this man flying flying cars to
mars how dare he not step into our
policy this is why [ __ ] everything's
politics now man i know so so so i'm not
[ __ ] insane when i when i say like
wow that sounded really really mild
you know that sounded like really really
mild i don't know uh if i could be
outraged at someone saying something so
goddamn mild
it's interesting it's like well he
didn't say exactly what i wanted him to
say when i wanted him to say it
now what if he just didn't make a tweet
was was he required to make a tweet or
something
okay no no no you wasn't required to
make a tweet at all but so then
so what if you didn't say anything at
all he would probably end up getting
asked in a press conference or something
i don't it's really really weird this is
very very very strange
it's an interesting question right like
what
requirement do you have as a person of
influence to weigh in on a conversation
that you don't care about so i asked
someone this question the other day
about joe rogan
is it joe rogan's responsibility
to
let's say that he doesn't care about
kovitz let's say he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about covid um is it joe rogan's
responsibility to have conversations
about it simply because he has a
platform that allows him to reach a lot
of people
is it elon musk's responsibility because
he has a large platform and he's an
influential person to talk about i i
think this was in response to texas's
abortion law right yes um so i have an
answer for this well it depends on what
side they're gonna take
okay it depends on if elon musk is uh
you know for abortion well he probably
shouldn't have spoken up but if he
uh you know is or sorry sorry if he is
for the six-week ban on on abortions
um well then he probably should have
shut up right but if he has any inkling
of
uh
you know dissent from greg abbott and
his decision then yes he needs to speak
up
right well it
this is by the way this is not my
uh i don't i'm not swaying either way
i'm just saying it's like what are you
not committing zach are you not
committing are you not having an opinion
this is being a [ __ ] right
if it's not your opinion lay your
opinion down on the line zach what the
[ __ ] are you doing here
do you know how many people fought for
the vote so that you could have the vote
in the freedom in the [ __ ] south of
america to drive your big stupid truck
around and you're not taking advantage
of the opportunity to do that you know
you have a voice use it
what what about this though how about
when when what what about when
we take people we're mad at people for
not speaking up because they have a
platform but at the same time we will
diminish their opinion because they're
not a professional in
said thing that we want them to talk
about
you know it's like if joe rogan says
something about politics maybe
maybe that that's not the greatest
example but someone could say [ __ ] that
guy he's a comedian what does he know
about politics that's only if he doesn't
agree with your point of view exactly
but if he does agree with your point of
view it's his obligation to speak upon
politics
what people are doing all that
everyone's looking for each side is
looking to get the biggest gun that they
can and bring it to the fight
what's the largest artillery battering
ram that we can bring have we got joe
rogan on our side have we got elon musk
on our side and then if you find out
that he's actually firing against you if
he's batting for the other team you go
you do what you can to describe i mean
it's fairly obvious right like it's just
normal human
political status game playing when
somebody's on your side you back them up
you enhance their credentials when
somebody's on the other side you try to
diminish their impact yeah
it's uh
just
people are so easily propagandized is
that a word propagandized
and um
it has to be
right or wrong good or evil
and if some people are figuring out
you know not that they're in between
they're literally waiting and they're
just figuring things out and they're
trying to develop an opinion or
taking in more things it's your fault
for not doing it fast enough yeah
and i'm definitely one of those
people and i know you are too yeah so my
my website says learning out loud like
that's the tagline that's what i'm doing
i'm trying to work out my views in the
world the problem is
people jump to conclusions
because
being an absolutist or having a
non-nuanced point of view
comes across like authenticity and
authority
if you are just completely like
single-minded about this topic and i
know and my mind's made up
that looks a lot like being an authority
right and and really understanding your
talking points but the narrow-minded
person and the person that's done all of
the research kind of end up at the same
point if they believe that same point of
view it's a person in the middle that
gets absolutely wrecked for going well i
actually think that i probably could do
with being doing a little bit more
research maybe it's not for me this
isn't the hill that i want to die on in
fact i didn't even ask to be a part of
this conversation
but here's another thing man regarding
this the the new texas abortion law
which for anyone that doesn't know is
a law which outlaws abortion after six
weeks and anybody that is caught
assisting somebody that can even be like
the uber driver that drives them to the
planned parenthood place can be fined up
to ten thousand dollars did you see that
leaders of the satanic temple aren't
just outraged with texas's strict new
abortion lord they say it's also a
matter of religion did you see this
no okay so leaders of the satanic temple
consistent with all our tenets that call
for bodily autonomy and acting in
accordance with the best scientific
evidence the satanic temple based in
salem religiously objects to many of the
restrictions that state have enacted
that interfere with abortion access the
religious group's website says temple
officials are also taking matters into
their own hands lucian greaves uh
satanic temple's co-founder and
spokesperson said the temple has sent a
letter to the u.s food and drug
administration citing religious freedom
to seek the ability to provide its
members with abortion pharmaceuticals as
part of and i quote its satanic abortion
ritual within the first 24 weeks of
pregnancy
i thought first off that this was like
some you get pregnant
are we normal are we normalizing
satanism
apparently they've got half a million uh
subscribing members in uh great which is
more subs than me and you've got
i'm sure someone will find a way to
slander my name for saying that hey
maybe maybe being a satanist isn't that
great of a thing
maybe
you know maybe satanism isn't uh
a uh a good route to go down
well they are managing religious freedom
here so to qualify for abortion
this is the thing right i think
okay yeah so i thought that what they
did was it was some like really really
evil thing where people would get
pregnant and then they'd like celebrate
killing the baby it turns out it's not
that it turns out it's even it's kind of
weirder than that
what they do
they deliver
abortion pharmaceuticals
so they they actually deliver it so that
you go through the satanic temple you
get clearance from a medical
professional yeah and then
it goes to the american college of
obstetricians and gynecologists uh and
then this is a quote from that guy who
said so it wouldn't really be any
different to if they just went to a
practitioner and got it directly from
them it's just we would be the ones
distributing it so like
they they do multiple things not only do
you go to them to worship satan but you
can also
have you have your abortion
but see at what point does being a
satanist really mean being a satanist
you know a lot of times people will be
like
hey you know
you worship the devil and then
maybe a satanist back to them would be
like no actually
we focus on the main tenets of and they
wouldn't even say the word satan they
would
it has to do with choice and all this
stuff when all of a sudden it's evolving
into another religion in an of itself
you know at a certain point regardless
of whether
they believe one thing or another
it is a pretty nice virtue signal for
the satanist
you know that whatever the satanist
group is
to announce that they are
providing uh
abortions or abortions depends on what
side of the aisle you're on if you're if
you're trying to get right if you're
trying to get the conservatives to be
all well yeah but you'll never get the
conservatives when you're when your
group is called a satanist but
you know there's i'm sure there's a lot
of people on board with the satanism
satanists now and i cannot believe this
is our conversation this is wait i
haven't finished believe it i've got you
i've got another [ __ ] one so you
thought that the satan thing was crazy
okay so
um this is an article that looked at the
differences between men and women's
views on abortion so oh i think i
suspected i shared it the other day
polls consistently show that women are
more likely than men to support a
reduction in the abortion limit in 2011
a yuge of poll 28 of men supported a
reduction 46 percent of women did 2012
24 of men and 49 percent of women so
that's gone down for men and up for
women uh in an angus reed poll uh 35 of
men's 59 of women and then 45 percent of
men and 59 women this raises some pretty
big implications the most obvious being
that if it were left to women to vote on
the issue with men out of the picture
there's a good chance that the result
would be in favor of restricting
abortion on the flip side if only men
voted they'd almost certainly vote in
favor of women's reproductive rights
let's break that down because that's
really interesting
why
is that
why is that
they put forward a bunch of different
potential explanations yeah um
one of them being that women who go
through childbirth
are part of that group and if you've had
a child if you have given birth to a
child right your support for abortion
seems to go down quite yeah sort of
rightly so you it's magical you realize
that this is the sort of thing you want
your friends to enjoy and experience and
build families
yep that makes sense
and then
i i just think of like whenever i think
of more men
if it was possible i mean this is what i
would think more men want abortion
because it's just a bunch of bros who
don't want kids
you know it's it but obviously it's not
the case wait no it is the case right so
men men are vying for more abortion or
more men are vying for abortion rights
that's correct right yes yes so because
we're just a bunch of bros that's it so
what they're saying is that this is this
is this still got linked around somehow
this got linked around to the
misogynistic patriarchal substruct
substrate construct that
overarches everything and said well look
what's happening here this is obvious
it's obvious that men are just trying to
control women's bodies still they're
permitting them to have their body their
choice but this just permits men to
spray it around as much as they want and
not really time their withdrawal method
too well
yep wait so
that wait i'm sorry so the assumption
that more men would vote for abortion
leads you to that or is it the other way
around so
men want to have a
reduction
in the number of restrictions on
abortion which means that more people
will be able to get them which would
permit them to have more sex more
liberally with less protection and less
good timing on their withdrawals
it's one of those things where it's like
um
there there is no opposing the argument
because you use the opposition of the
argument against them there's a really
good one um
the i forget who it was it was one of
the gracies which the gracies are the
founding
family of brazilian jiu jitsu
and there is this lore of
i think it might have been helio gracie
but
i'm not entirely sure but he went to
fight uh kimura
which now is a common uh
it's a common like attack that we use in
jiu jitsu and kimura is a japanese i
think like judoka so judo whatever and
um
they made this huge thing that um
you know it was a it was a massive fight
and helio was like 50 pounds underweight
and
you know gave kimura the greatest fight
of his life
and kimura ended up beating him
um
fast forward to
you know later
i think it was hicks and gracie
um and did you have him on your show by
the way no i decided against it
okay
uh we can talk about that in a bit but
uh you read his book i think right yeah
okay so basically hicks and gracie i
think was beat by someone
um and what the gracie said was he used
good like gracie style jiu jitsu to beat
us
i'm not sure if they said that against
the about the kimura fight
but that's kind of the idea is like
even if you beat me
you know it's because of the ideas that
i had
that you beat me yeah right which is the
same thing here what's happening here is
that you have you have an ideology
and then you try and wrap you trap rap
reality around that ideology so it's
unfalsifiable and no matter what
direction you come at it from
it's still yeah i mean that's always fun
isn't it you're in
austin texas right now i mean are there
people on this very [ __ ]
like protesting this is anyone talking
about it in the gym
uh it's it's a very liberal city so so
people might not understand that they
must be pissed
yeah i think um you know just go on
instagram and you can find a lot more
pissed people about this
you know across the country it's very
interesting that at the in the same week
that greg
greg abbott the governor says
that uh abortions will not be allowed
um after six weeks
of pregnancy
that conceal and carry does not require
uh a license anymore what's that mean
so you can conceal a weapon or a firearm
uh without having a license or without
having to get gain a license do you need
a special kind of license to do a
concealed carry because presumably you
need one for the gun but then you need
extra training so i don't want to carry
it
that's usually the case right so you
usually go to like a weekend
training course you have to i think you
have to take some tests and then you
have to file and then you can get your
uh conceal and carry
and i believe that now it's almost
completely
gone that that concealing carry
you know bylaw where you have to take a
course people walking around so we
like the same week that we we have now
have like the most lenient gun control
laws we have the most extreme abortion
laws
so people think that texas is [ __ ]
crazy yeah okay
um but if you go to i'm telling you
austin primarily is a liberal city
like
very proud it's it's one of the you know
portland's
uh what's another very like san
francisco it's a very liberal place
people are obviously upset
my
my thing is this this it to me
the whole six week being the most the
the most extreme abortion law in the
country by far
it's more of a statement than than
necessity
it's just trying to be extreme for
extremes sake do you think that's the
same with the gun carry thing yes
so what's the goal why would governor
rabbit want this
i don't know i'm not entirely sure i
never really thought about the
motivation but these are things that
certain people can do to
you know
i think obviously governors end up
trying to run for president
or trying to run for senate or you know
house of representatives
and maybe this is a ploy to gain
you know more conservative followers
people that are going to eventually want
like the most possible conservative
candidate right ron desantis that's in
florida
yes yeah he's crushed it the last sort
of 18 months right like he's yeah well
it depends on what side your roof it
you know it depends on what side you're
on i mean i would say
again i'm i'm not going to try to lean
any direction here because that's not my
place but again i might get elon musk
elon musk [ __ ] if i
if i if i don't say anything if i don't
make my position known but yeah you're
right i would say you know
objectively his approval ratings have
gone up yeah you know everything's been
been good for him in florida but
plenty of people would disagree with the
things that he's done and the things
that he said speaking of guns man i've
started i've started getting into
airsoft youtube
oh yeah the sniper have you seen the
sniper video yeah yeah is it guys dutch
the someone he's called
[ __ ] man anyone anyone that hasn't seen
this it is sick so it's just that [ __ ]
these guys in full ghillie suits full
sort of military apparel and they've got
they're shooting plastic bbs but these
weapons that they have are so
sophisticated and they've got gopros
mounted on everything they've got a
gopro through the scope of the sniper
rifle one on the gun so you can see the
guy one facing forward so you can see
what he's doing
man it is it's some of the best youtube
that i've ever watched there's this one
where he does no head shots and the guy
starts complaining about headshots so
from 100 yards away he hits this dude in
the dick
[Laughter]
you gotta love youtube rabbit holes you
have to love the random
nature of them what did i recently watch
oh i went down a cricket rabbit hole
good man that's better that's more like
it yeah it was really cool it was really
really really cool you when you come
over we're gonna go watch a match
okay cool it's the the twi what is it
twenties twenty twenty yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm down i dude i i saw there was
like a uh a netflix or no not a netflix
something was just like a vice special
explaining cricket that's like the most
american thing that you could have
because we have those explaining here's
the history of baseball because over
here we've got no [ __ ] idea yeah it
used to be played with a pig skin and
you're like oh basically basically we
invented baseball because we've hated uh
the uk cricket yeah you wanted your own
bastardized version of cricket basically
yeah we i mean that's essentially what
it came down to like everyone was
playing cricket over here and then
we did the old uh the old war
and then we were like yeah we can't be
playing this [ __ ] switcheroo have you
seen the new matrix trailer no i haven't
[ __ ] and i am a huge by the way i i saw
a screenshot of it and it was so someone
was like this is
this is neo playing keanu or [ __ ] this
this is just
playing john wick being neo or something
yeah because he looks so much like
[ __ ] john do you know why i think it
might have been
and this happened with
didn't it happen with that [ __ ] guy
that plays superman didn't they
because he was in the middle of playing
some other role where they wouldn't
allow him to shave his beard off
superman the entirety of zack snyder's
justice league superman thing he had to
have a beard and they cgi'd the beard
off his face no way dude i swear to god
the guy that plays superman you know
they can just do makeup beards
no so he didn't need a bead he needed to
not have a beard you can't make up a
beard away yeah but he wasn't allowed to
have to not have a beard for another
movie yes but they had to cgi the
[ __ ] beard off i know what i'm saying
with the other movie they could have
allowed him to shave his face and then
they put a fake beard on well [ __ ] them
you know whoever's got the con whoever's
got the bigger contract anyway uh keanu
reeves i reckon he might be ready for a
new john wick and that's why they
haven't allowed him to shave the beard
oh that's my theory anyway the dude the
trailer did you not use the website that
was up yesterday where you got to pick
the red pill or the blue pill
no i i'm gonna do it okay listen i'm a
what is more important than this i am a
massive massive matrix fan let me tell
you i
like
i would say once a year i sit down and i
watch the trilogy straight up and
everyone loves to rip on um
what is it reloaded yeah and
the new one that's coming out is
resurrected right i can't i can't even
think of
whatever that one third one god what oh
revolutions yeah so reloaded in
revolutions dude they're good
they are good
everyone
no they're good no they're okay okay
look maybe maybe it's because i'm so
into like
the possibilities and like the the
actual sci-fi
that i can't even watch
like the cinematic do you not think that
they lost a lot of that like that the
the most interesting stuff was to do
with the relationship between the real
world and the machine world and so much
of that just got lost when you had these
guys in these mech suits just shooting
the ceiling for ages okay but that [ __ ]
didn't interest me none of that [ __ ]
interested me the coolest thing dude was
like the the ending was so cool
it was so cool basically the entire time
they knew
the whole purpose of the one and all of
that wasn't a plant everything was a
plant but the the thing that no one
expected was that was mr anderson
you know what i'm saying and so
when neo allows himself to be overtaken
by mr anderson and then
ends up destroying this thing whatever
it is like to me that thing kept me
going throughout the entire thing i
actually that's the thing i was blinded
probably by how interested i was in the
in the plot
you were able to get rid of the the
awful yeah like shooting the mech suits
at the ceiling and stuff like that yeah
that probably sucked yeah i'd but except
i don't even this new trailer get out of
my memory this new trailer
[ __ ] crushes yeah it's i mean it's so
good i'm sold yeah i'm so sold
like
so here's another thing right so
i i don't do i'm on i'm on tick tock
technically i'm on tick tock but right
the guy that looks after my social media
posts for me on tick tock so i don't i
don't have the login you've got a social
media guy oh yeah of course yeah little
humble flex for you there
so
what's interesting right i got involved
in tick-tock drama apparently um because
i posted a video about the friendzone
not existing
uh oh yeah and
people got upset
but i didn't know
that it was happening
and then i
got like a notification saying hey man
like just fyi one of these videos has
sort of caught a little bit of fire and
it had like 100 000 views or whatever
and some some people were upset
but i remember
noticing the fact that all of this [ __ ]
was going on because of something i
actually said like i genuinely did say
and i still stand by it that men over
estimate the attraction that women have
to them and women underestimate the
attraction that men have to them which
means that the friend zone for one
person isn't the same as the friend zone
for another in speed dating self-reports
of relative attraction men presume that
the woman is more attracted to them than
she reports and women presume that the
man is less attracted so when you talk
about the friend zone
if you're a man and a woman talking
about that you're talking past each
other because the world that each of you
inhabit is basically different right
yeah yeah people got upset
here's the [ __ ] takeaway
drama happened and i wasn't involved so
i kind of watched it unfold and was like
huh how silly like drama that i don't
care about because it's just on this
silly little app i was like
oh wait that's all of the drama that
i've been involved in for the last 15
years the difference
and i don't care about that one
yes yes i i totally i
i as a very casual tick talker very very
casual tick-tocker i made one that went
semi-viral i don't know how many views
or likes or whatever it has at this
point i made it for fun
and uh like woke up the next morning and
it was going going pretty crazy
and i was like wow this is so cute look
at this little thing go
you know and i realized like why would i
not give legitimacy to this stupid app
and then give legitimacy to
anything else
you know they're all owned by some
you know [ __ ] at the top
that can shut it all down at any point
and like
it's so funny man like
the tick-tock space
it's just gonna turn into everything
else
i think there i think we're still in
this like wild west
uh phase of tick tock and maybe there
was a wild west phase of instagram and
that's i think that's ending literally
as we speak
um and there's a wild west of reddit and
i'm sure that's going to be shut down
pretty soon
uh what do you think happens what's the
difference between when it's a wild west
and when it's not well when it's a wild
west thing it's like people are still
trying to navigate it so it's like
you don't you see some pretty crazy
stuff you see some stuff that maybe you
shouldn't see you post things you
shouldn't post
um it's kind of great actually you
really get to see people for who they
are and who you know and what they
comment i
on instagram i
just said i love saying sarcastic [ __ ]
to my friends like making fun of them
like
if someone was like what if i do this
well i go well it's because you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you should work harder
totally a joke one of my friends they
understand that's sarcastic boom
immediately i was silenced on instagram
for that comment i've been reported for
harassment and bullying but not reported
i think the algorithm took that
you can't make a funny [ __ ] comment
anymore to your friend meanwhile on tick
tock this girl's encouraging other ones
to go and do anorexia as [ __ ] diet
regimes but the but the tick tock
algorithm now is is starting to suppress
everything i mean i i was um
one of my other tick tocks did really
really well
it was me reading uh
this guy's dm to
uh to another guy it was like a [ __ ]
talk a ufc fighter
oh yeah i saw it i saw it did you see
that yeah yeah okay so this ufc fighter
is uh a crazy person he's an actual
crazy person sean strickland you train
and this other guy dylan dannis who did
some like jiu jitsu training for conor
mcgregor that's how he blew up he's
really nothing special
uh
i also i will say this i think he was a
black belt world champion in the ghee
uh or he's he's won some major things
but
um
he said like sean strickland posted
something to his story and
uh immediately after
dylan danis was like oh so you had to
take down that story post on me like
never come at the king and then sean
strickland goes on this diatribe about
how he would
how he would uh make him see his own
blood before turning his mind off for
good
nothing would please him more than to
take his life with his bare hands like
not the type of [ __ ] talk is like
you know where you're kind of like
pumping your chest it was like the type
of [ __ ] talk that a psychopath would
make
you know
like i'm gonna eat your liver with uh
some fava beans and a nice chianti type
of thing
okay and i posted that i thought it was
really funny i posted that to instagram
did really well i posted that the tick
tock was taken down
chinese don't like you man chinese do
not like you but is that who's running
like the [ __ ] knows i don't know
i don't get it
no one knows anymore but it's a silly
little app man and it's all of them are
that was the thing that was what i know
i was like
because i watched it from the outside
and i was like look my value judgment
means that i'm not bought in personally
to this i don't care
so why do i care about all of you well
because those ones are the cool ones
yeah but those are the legitimate ones
exactly exactly yeah no
they're all silly and
what we do is meaningless i saw a tweet
from the fda
talking about ivamekton
that said
you are not a horse
you are not a cow
seriously y'all stop it
that's
those are the people
in charge of your country's okay food
and drug administration okay here we go
so listen the fda
uh
from what i've seen is is an absolute
joke and can be bought and sold now that
doesn't that doesn't delegitimize the
fact that you know one should or
shouldn't get vaccinated that's not what
i'm saying
a lot of their suggestions
on sugar intake artificial
you know sweeteners intake like it's
just off and you can tell it's
they've been basically bought and sold
rather than being outright and and
forthright and telling people how they
should
you know eat and live better lives
through the food that they eat
they
you know allow these um crisps
to give free doughnuts away to people
that got vaccinated
yes and
this is one of those things and you'll
see it on tick tocks okay i'm glad both
of these things are are kind of coming
full circle
there's like friend zone tick tock okay
and one of them is like dancing with my
best friend and it's like you know it's
a girl and a guy and they're like
they're about to kiss and they fake kiss
and then they start dancing or whatever
and all of the comments are talking
about how great of a guy that guy is
it's like kind of the inside joke it's
like um
like
let's say the guy's name is chris okay
the comments will be like
you know my grandma was dying she was
dying she was on the street dying and
chris came out and and gave her
open-heart surgery on the street thank
god for chris or else my grandma would
be dead what does this have to do with
the fda
okay so
mlb major league baseball comments
chris invented
baseball like
major league baseball yeah okay
you so now you see
and by the way that's a massive
corporation
massive so much money and they're
commenting on a viral tick tock about a
kid getting friend zoned they're trying
to it is now the usurping of
being an actual advertisement making an
actual psa that is where we're at right
now the fda will make a snarky comment
on twitter to sound cool saying y'all
y'all are not cows y'all are not horses
okay that's where we're at so you're
saying that even the fda will sell their
soul for clout
yeah of course i i wouldn't be surprised
if the fda hops on tick tock and starts
making smarmy snarky comments i think it
started with you know slim jim on
instagram no
honestly one of the funniest
one of the funniest accounts
and no no doubt about it has worked
tremendously for their advertising it's
like
slim jim taco bell all these kind of
like funny they make they do stoner
comedy they
a great way to promote your brand is
comment well
i don't think anyone's [ __ ] saying
that
everyone listening everyone watching
write that [ __ ] down if you can make a
good comment
it's just as big now
if not bigger in some cases
than the actual content itself everyone
loves those super threads where kfc goes
at burger king goes at mcdonald's goes
at subway goes it
right but and but think about it like
this if there's a piece of content that
someone works tirelessly on
and then someone comments something
funny snarky and
real
and it gets
10 000 likes
that took them a fraction of me on the
amount of time with
that you know almost as much of the
interaction
and so like this is where we're at
when is that going to run out when is
that going to become less funny not yet
not yet my friend when is the fda gonna
gonna [ __ ] make a comment on
you know doja cat's
next tweet
and when is it not gonna be [ __ ]
funny when is the fda you're going to
start selling nfts that's what i want i
want an fda nft
i still don't even really know what an
nft is i've got it i don't i don't care
don't explain it to me rushing it
terrifying amounts of money
okay i don't know i don't really i
understand what they are but i think
that most people like them in the same
way that most people like crypto most
people like crypto because they make
tons of money off it it's like all right
if the ability to make profit from your
bitcoin or your ethereum or your
litecoin or whatever if that was taken
away how much would you still care about
technology because everyone's like bro
i'm for technology
no you're not you're for making money
that's what you for not to technology
you don't give a [ __ ] about people in
africa that want to be able to send
money back to their grandparents you
don't care about people they're in
war-torn countries what you care about
is the fact that bitcoin doubles every
three years that's what you're bothered
about stop it just be open about it i
like bitcoin
because when i put money in more money
comes out wait there are people that are
saying otherwise i was unaware of this
well there's people there are people
that are like that are virtue signaling
they're they're there's people that hide
their desire to invest in bitcoin behind
a screen that says i just love the
technology it's all about the blockchain
what i'm really excited by the
potentials for web 3.0 i want to be able
to own my own information
what a crack a horseshit that is no you
want to be able to own a [ __ ] huge
mansion and you think that having a
bunch of bitcoin is going to help you
when the price rises yeah [ __ ] you
how about that again why do we have to
[ __ ] virtue signal for everything
because if you were to admit the truth
it would be embarrassing if you were to
admit i am a red-blooded capitalist that
wants to make money by putting my money
into this thing i don't know
i know a bit about it enough to hold a
conversation but i don't really care i
don't really care about what it does but
i want to make money people
what signals that no one's going to like
you for that of course you're not going
to say that what you're going to say is
something nice and virtuous that makes
you seem good and empathetic
of course you are
everyone's virtue signaling all the time
actually i i did see that by the way
just by saying that someone is virtue
signaling almost you are virtua
signaling because you're creating that
separation between you and them i'm not
them yeah so i have an episode with this
guy called will store which you're going
to [ __ ] love about the status game so
it's all about this all about how
different people play status games
[ __ ] fascinating man you know that
that um i honestly i some of these
things some of these movies some of
these tv series i think about all the
goddamn time
and one of them is that black mirror
episode where it's like your social
score credits yeah
that one i think about all the time
i really really do how do you think your
social credit score would be
oh [ __ ]
i think it would be it would have to be
high right because just relatives what
about the problem that you watch
well that's the thing is like that's a
huge deduction right there yeah well
okay beyond porn it's like if i like a
porn star's picture
if i like if i like a picture of
somebody who has
liked a tweet from governor abbott
[ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] for that honest to god i
actually saw this thing where it takes
an algorithm they people who are hiring
people they run your
twitter
facebook everything through an algorithm
they see who you liked and who you liked
what have they liked
and they can give you like this score
on on the safety of hiring this type of
person
yeah i saw it i saw a guy who got denied
a job or a job application or a job
review
a bunch of his tweets got highlighted
and they printed off
the last
like three years of everything that he'd
interacted with they'd use some similar
sort of program that highlighted
problematic tweets and problematic
accounts that he'd followed so yeah i've
seen something similar did you see that
rogan is talking about suing cnn for
saying that he was using
uh what was it horsty wermer ivamekton
okay but okay but listen he went like
this he he literally went like this
should i [ __ ] should i [ __ ] sue
cnn dude
like kind of like that
very in passing that just goes to show
how powerful that dude's voice is
he opened the show talking about the
dewormer thing and he goes [ __ ] should i
sue uh cnn
and like
i don't know i don't know how serious
that was i don't think it's very serious
at all no
but but um
basically
it's really funny
because i did see you know philip
defranco you know phil defranco
he's a you know big youtuber kind of
like a news guy
and he's just like i'm so sick of he he
goes crazy
he goes crazy on joe rogan
and what's funny is what does he say if
i mean he went he went nuts he was like
i'm so sick and tired of the same [ __ ]
uh you know like
you know joe rogan not pushing the
vaccine and and giving misinformation
and all this stuff
and it sounded weird because it's like
did you even watch
the full video that rogan had made
again it was so non
politically charged it was so nice it
was so hopeful he had a smile on his
face he was in his back [ __ ] yard he
was he was like look we did everything
we could we we sent everything through
the kitchen sink at it we threw the
kitchen sink at it i you know i had
ivermectin as well i had this this and
this i rested up i stayed and i feel
great and i'm just really happy to be
here and i'm all this [ __ ] and everyone
took that and phil defranco himself took
that and was like look at this [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
i i'm sorry if you were to take someone
who had just never interacted with the
world just an alien and brought them
down here and they watched someone say
what they what they had said they would
have been like oh that's completely
inconsequential and i just don't give a
[ __ ] because it was just so mild
and then they walk away is it not the
same people that are saying joe rogan
shouldn't have put this weird stuff in
his body because it's a bad virtue
signal to everyone else that are also
saying my body my choice with regards to
the texas abortion law
so
wait say that one more time
people are complaining about the fact
that rogan's used experimental drugs on
himself right he is in a position of
influence and other people may decide to
do the same thing
that also say
abortion shouldn't be restricted down to
six weeks my body my choice well see
rogan's body rogan's choice that doesn't
work
ah
interesting you've thought about that
one huh joel did that just come to just
this just came to your mind yep
oh man you're good at this you're a pro
so
yeah i mean that's the always the cool
the funniest thing is if you're if
you're saying listen i don't want to
wear a mask i don't want to take a
vaccine if i don't have to you better be
saying
you know you can get an abortion if you
want um because it's your body your
choice it's my body my choice vaccine or
not whatever
and uh that is a very very interesting
point
you know the thing that's interesting i
think about rogan's situation is how the
press responded to it so it's the fact
that every
opportunity for something to become
politicized
someone tries to take them for part of
his team so because roger hasn't had the
vaccine the right decided to take this
as this is an opportunity for one of our
own to push back against this
totalitarian state that's trying to
force vaccines into our arms and so on
and so forth every topic
is an opportunity to score points
and and that sucks i'm sorry that sucks
i i i can't
when i was younger i don't think that it
was like this
isn't it i would like to think isn't it
telling i would like
probably because i've been so like
immersed
in what we do now that i can't even
remember a world in which
it wasn't like this
it's so wild bro so i've been watching
i've been watching a ton of the 911
documentaries recently yeah when you see
these people walking going up and down
escalators and no one's got a smartphone
and you just see these people and
they're stood there just holding the
handrail and just looking
okay just look at the real experience
sort of like look out of the [ __ ]
window and you're like god these people
are psychopaths what are they doing
without a phone in their hands
there here's a surreal experience
um and i wish
all i have is this one image
um so basically
when smartphones smartphones started to
come about first there was like
blackberry
and um i don't know if did you ever have
a blackberry yeah so blackberry message
when you beat the baby
god that was the [ __ ] bro that was the
[ __ ] but if you lost your phone you had
to get a new one because it was attached
to the phone it wasn't attached to the
number yes you had to get a new bbm oh
my god okay so
even then when we had smartphones people
weren't on them as much because
instagram wasn't around
and um
just going on the internet wasn't fun it
was like i would google things but it
wasn't like bing bing like awesome like
swipe up swipe down that was the golden
era because you had group chats you were
able to message girls you were able to
send photos and videos you could google
stuff but you didn't get distracted with
facebook instagram or twitter and
so there was that
it's still the wild west of the
smartphone i love it right okay so
then it kind of moves on the iphone
and
at one point
i realized that everyone was on their
phone
and i swear when i tell you this
i looked up from my phone one day
and i saw every single person looking
down at their phone every single person
i think it was either
it was either a bus or an airport
right because that's what you do in
these places and i remember being like
wow this is [ __ ] weird this is
[ __ ] weird
everyone's looking at their phones
old young everyone is doing that that's
[ __ ] crazy and i remember for the
next year and a half i'm like dude this
is [ __ ] whack everyone is looking
down at their phone
you know like the world is going on
around you all this [ __ ] now it's like
if i don't have this thing on me when
i'm playing anything boring
total panic attack if i see someone
without their phone in front of their
face what the [ __ ] is wrong with that
person yeah you know what i mean but
that that era
it's really hard to think about but
they're i swear when i tell you this
there was a singular moment where i
where i finally watched the [ __ ]
precipice occur yeah exactly jesus
christ the corner it was like one week
prior i wouldn't have noticed it yeah
that moment and from every day forward
that is our reality and it's only gonna
get even more trippy man
have you seen so we looked at this wall
street journal article about the
declining college rates for men have you
seen this floating around
no dude this is going on this article is
[ __ ] scary so i've known this for
quite a while but it's really just
starting to hit mainstream media and one
of the reasons that it's probably not
too popular amongst mainstream media is
that it goes counter to a narrative that
men are outperforming women and there's
this oppressive patriarchal construct
that's misogynistically trying to keep
people down blah blah blah are people
still on that are people still on that
massively massively so okay the number
of men enrolled at two and four-year
colleges has fallen behind women by
record levels in a widening education
gap across the u.s men are abandoning
higher education in such numbers that
they will now trail female college
students by record levels at the close
of the 2020 2021 academic year women
made up 59.5 of college students an
all-time high in men 40.5
according to enrollment data from the
national student clearinghouse a
nonprofit research group in the us
colleges and universities had 1.5
million fewer students compared with
five years ago and men accounted for 71
of that decline in the next few years
two women will earn a college degree for
every man american colleges have yet to
reach a consensus on what might slow the
retreat of men from higher education
i think people are
this could go a number of ways this
discussion and i this is actually this
is
critical to where we are
you know in society as a whole
how valuable
is
an education and what about
being a man
would would provide a man to say this
isn't as valuable you know as opposed to
a woman
what about their psychology
is saying that or allowing that to
happen and then also
in what way will the media suppress this
you know
if the narrative is so i'm not convinced
that the media can really suppress the
stats like you can in within 10 years as
you walk around on campus you're going
to see double the number of women as you
do men i don't know the equivalent for
the uk but in the us that's going to be
the case like there's it's not about
suppressing the stats like there is no
suppressing that some of the reasons
that you could put forward for why this
may have occurred is that there has been
quite a negative environment for men
generally in the universities um
quite rightly women have had to have
their spaces be made to feel better the
metoo movement was like [ __ ] long
overdue to call powerful men to account
for taking advantage of women
um
but what it's done is it's taken quite a
broad brush and applied that to all men
when the research suggests that it's a
small minority of men that commit almost
all of the sexual offenses this is what
david bust discovered uh evolutionary
psychologists that i had on the show
that the vast majority of men aren't
sexual predators but a small number of
men commit [ __ ] tons of acts but if
you tar everybody with a quite a broad
brush if you make it a little bit of a
hostile environment in which men feel
quite uncomfortable then that's not so
good you've also got like the equivalent
of affirmative affirmative action
programs that promote girls success
within high school and within college
applications i'm not sure if you have
outright sort of gendered discrimination
when it comes to accepting into courses
i would imagine no
but
i think it's significantly harder for
boys to get through school if you are
someone that's more physically minded if
you're someone who's got adhd but
previously there was so much prestige
and status associated with an education
that you would be able to you would be
prepared to go through that there's a
lot of discomfort associated with me
sitting on my ass and [ __ ] having to
learn all of this stuff and i want to be
outside playing or play fighting or
building something or doing whatever but
i'll get through it because the college
is going to be worth it and um
yeah now two to one females to males
within the next ten years at college
that is crazy two to one yeah at every
college here's the thing um and i think
i might have talked about this on the
the last podcast that i did with you a
year and a half ago but
colleges in america and for those who
are listening in the uk and the rest of
the world colleges in america are unlike
anything you've ever [ __ ] seen before
what do you mean and all you have to do
is go to a collegiate football game to
understand exactly what i'm saying they
make millions of dollars off ticket
sales per game
they
make
over you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars from
anything from like selling apparel to
food
tv rights millions of dollars
uh
all of this in
as a way you know think about it like
countries that what they do for the
olympics to kind of flex their prowess
without actually having to go to war
this is what colleges are doing
and it's a prestige
yes
yes and it is a war it is an all-out
[ __ ] war and there's a
conference called the sec which is the
southeast conference and that one is the
most powerful one
uh as far as money
it's ridiculous what's this got to do
with men and women in college well it's
it's basically the importance of college
isn't what we think it is
there's so much of it is like we have so
so i can speak from uh a perspective of
someone who lived in an area a college
station where texas a m is there are 60
000 undergrads 60 000 people at a school
that is ridiculous the amount of money
that goes into that school
how much prestige is there really when
there's 60 000 other people doing the
same thing you are now mind you some of
them are engineers some of them are
medical students
trying to get law degrees that's a
different
you know all together
but what we have is this massive money
making industry trying to
coax people to get into these colleges
and go to college and maybe take on debt
when the reality is there's not much
prestige anymore
and maybe there never really was
but it's kind of starting to be away
maybe i don't know so are you saying
that girls that men have seen the the
light and taken the red pill in college
and girls have still got the whole
pulled over eyes maybe honestly because
think about how
think think about how men interact with
the internet
and how it may be different with the way
women do
you know if
you know and this is again this is we're
talking through it here this no
i think that you you're actually onto
something here and the reason that i do
is that for a long time women were told
the culture
and the powers that be told women you
have been oppressed for a very long time
um the only reason that you're able to
get a job is that you've got to fight
your way up there this is something that
you shouldn't deserve the only way that
you're able to get an education is
because you've had to so what that does
is
the the subtext to a lot of females is
i
the only way that i can get this is if i
really deserve it it puts it on a
pedestal it adds prestige to college
fake prestige but now like when it's
when you're talking 59 to 5 to 40
percent of 60 40 basically in terms of
the ratio like it's obvious that it's
not as difficult for girls to get into
college anymore but because you have
this sort of lagging measure
that's all of these sort of tradition
traditions in terms of culture that
people have still got that in their mind
a lot of girls may still have the idea
that i shouldn't be allowed to go to
college it still is something of
prestige this is me standing out
i think that there's something to that
yeah so they're they're they're coming
from us a place of like
not vengeance but
this this motivation they're behind yeah
that they're behind and this is their
way to be in front yeah that's that's
definitely possible
you know it's going to be multi-faceted
it's going to be something that is
encouraging girls to go it's going to be
something which is discouraging guys to
go so here's the [ __ ] here's the
implication man so david burst
father of evolutionary psychology he
wrote in 2015 he wrote about the
the challenges you have when you have an
asymmetry in terms of education between
men and women okay this is something
that you said quote we must look deeply
into our mating psychology to understand
the far-reaching consequences of the sex
ratio imbalance so that is when you have
a disproportionate number of one sex to
another uh in an area women and men have
both evolved multiple mating strategies
some of the gender pursue casual hookups
some committed partnerships some
alternate at different times of their
lives and some do both simultaneously
and although
a few social scientists deny the data
research overwhelmingly shows that men
harbor on average a greater desire for
sexual partner variety shock
men experience more frequent sexual
thoughts throughout the day have more
sexual fantasies involving multiple
partners and readily sign up for online
dating sites for the sole goal of casual
sex so a surplus of women among educated
groups caters precisely to this
dimension of men's sexual desires
because the rare agenda is always better
positioned to get what they want on the
mating market so what you see in
colleges where there is a surplus of
women and a scarcity of men is more
casual dating because the men get to
make the rules if there are fewer men
than there are women the women have to
compete and the only way that they can
compete is by playing the game that the
men want conversely
in a college where you have more men
than you do women you have more
long-term relationships because the men
have to play the game that the women
want
a surplus of women amongst educated
groups caters precisely to this
dimension of men's sexual desires
because the rare agenda is always better
positioned to get what they want on the
mating market
roll it forward a little bit you now
have two thirds to one-third educated
women to educated men on the whole women
don't want to date a man that is less
educated less rich and lower status than
them and also one that's shorter than
them you are going to have an ever
increasing group of women competing for
an ever decreasing group of high
performing men the men that sit below
them don't get don't don't win anything
so that there's more in cells there's
more underperforming men white collar
women don't want to date blue collar at
blue collar guys
and
most of the women even the ones that
went to college
they're now competing for this tight
group of chads at the [ __ ] super
performing rowing chads at the top and
the only ones that win at these [ __ ]
turbo weapons the 9 out of 10 and 10 out
of 10 guys that have got mbas the ones
who are able to outperform
intellectually socially and uh
monetarily the women they're the only
ones that are left that are able to date
so nobody wins except for chad
chad wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait why does it always
have to be okay but i was if it's two to
one all you have to do is make it into
college and you've got two to one odds
baby that's it that's not hard go to
tech getting into texas a m is not hard
you and i could right now take whatever
test necessary and get into texas a m
sorry i apologize to anyone that's
actually that's probably not true i
think it's actually a pretty prestigious
school
let's say like because you live there
and you don't want to be you'd only be
berated by them on the street no
okay let's let's do louisiana i've heard
from i've heard from people lsu you just
have to sign your name on a few tests
and they'll let you in that's what i've
heard from from from people who have
gone to lsu mind you i'm not not this is
okay so
what i got from this and i why i was
smiling while you were talking and i
didn't want to interrupt but i i did at
some point
was all you have to do then in 10 years
from now is just go to college and the
babes are going to come at you here's
one for you man the difference in right
swipes on tinder for a guy with a
master's degree versus a bachelor's
degree is
i want to say 90 more
so you get
if you've got a master's degree versus a
bachelor's degree on tinder this is in
john burgess anyone that wants to fact
check me this is in john burge's date
and omics
i i honest to god i'll tell you right
now i don't understand women
i
i just don't not in not in the sense of
like oh i don't understand them they're
stupid it's like no no like i literally
thought that i might have an inkling of
an understanding of what a woman ninety
percent what a woman thinks
i don't stick about for one year so if
you've got your bachelor's degree and
you think do i want to stick about and
do this masters that look man it's a
year of your life it's going to be a bit
expensive you're going to have to work
hard but dude 90 better conversions on
tinder for the rest of your life that's
what this should put on the enrollment
thing [ __ ] the course doesn't matter
about the course you get to have 90
better conversions on tinder dude if
if like uh all that these schools need
to do or start making snarky comments on
tick tock and then promoting their
programs
and and promoting their programs with uh
with stats like that
hey if you enroll now there's a nut and
you end up graduating our course there's
a 90 percent chance that you will get
more swipes than someone who does it
come on in
i'd go
i would probably
i did i did get a masters i did not for
that reason but
it worked out
yeah [ __ ] man yeah it's a mess it's a
it's a real [ __ ] mess and um
who knew who knew that you're gonna have
all of these hyper-educated hyper-rich
babes
walking around just
dry as the desert not able to get any
you know is that is it sucks for
everyone it even sucks it sucks for
women sucks for men the only people that
win are the high performing men
but it's not high performing to get into
college if it's two to one girls no so
it's women want a date up and across so
it wouldn't just be a guy with a college
degree it's usually equal or or above
state education so if [ __ ] if it if
this continues to happen and you have
women getting like masters level
education at some insane rate the guys
that want
if they do want to sort of play that
game they're going to have to continue
to
[ __ ] know what you're saying play
catch up because women women are the
sexual gatekeepers so they always
determine the minimum level that it goes
at the difference is obviously when
you're on a college campus that's got a
surplus of girls or anywhere so i think
new york city has far more women than
guys and you see the same thing there
that women adopt more male
uh
dating strategies because they need to
play the game that men are playing
yeah
[ __ ] it's
it's very very [ __ ] and i think
that
just online dating is again
we're at a period now
it's like the loading screen for online
dating you know there's the wild wild
west which i love that term
when tinder came out boy was that [ __ ]
fun i was in college that year
it was so fun dude i remember no one
really understood it i remember being on
tinder and running out of swipes in the
middle of a city
that's how few people were on the app
yeah yeah that it wasn't because you
actually ran out of swipes it was
because like there wasn't there was no
one less yeah right and that was fun
dude that was really fun and now we're
in this period where it's like okay now
the rubber's hitting the road
uh so to speak
and
we're trying to navigate what it does to
the human mind to have that many
people say that they're interested in
you
and when i mean that many many i mean
like 50 to 100
on one app
whether you're a girl looking for a guy
a guy looking for a girl so guys don't
get that many swipes typically on
average most guys get almost no swipes
almost you mean almost no like matches
correct yes
yes so so what happens though if like
if a girl
or a guy has
four or five even five or six seven
eight nine ten i think if you do it long
enough
there's there's a chance that you can
get up to ten i would say i know women
have hundreds i know they do i've seen
women have shown me their apps and she's
like
and it just goes on
what is that what does that do
to one's psyche do we know what it does
do we understand it yet or are we still
in this loading screen are we still kind
of just determining
where we go from here fifty percent of
couples last year met online
right and that number is going to keep
going up
you know that number
you know that's online you know that
number's going to go up next year it'll
be 60
right
are we capable is our brains capable of
understanding 50 different people and
determining which mate suits us
i don't think we are i don't think we
just being exposed to this many people
is so
weird
i think we talked about this maybe we
have talked about it in passing because
you and i talk a lot
but the fact that we are exposed to so
many interactions on a personal level so
if someone
comments man this video is awesome chris
you make great content seriously i think
you're a great guy
let's say there's hundreds of those on a
on a one video which by the way is
possible and it has happened for you
that amount of positive interactions is
not okay for the human psyche
it's not
okay
because what does that do to your ego
and then as soon as someone says
something negative what does that do to
your ego
you know
how how ill-equipped is your ego to take
on one negative thing because you get
hundreds of positive things a day now
take that into the dating space you have
a hundred matches
what does that say about
how you're going to interact with a
potential mate in the future what are
you going to do
when
you know someone is actually suited for
you in real life but in the in your
pocket you have a hundred other suitors
i don't know if we're we're ready for
that
no no we're not in short
we're not humans aren't designed to
[ __ ] consume the entire world's news
in real time 24 hours a day of course
we're [ __ ] not like all of this
hypernormal stimuli just [ __ ] everybody
up
but it's here to stay
so this is the thing like for a long
time i got really irritated i still am i
i feel bad about my phone use even if
it's half an hour a day because i
usually in retrospect don't enjoy the
time that i spent on my phone i wish i'd
spent it in a different way
and for a while i remember sort of
fighting against it and thinking about
how i could make the world a different
place and now it's more like okay this
is here to stay how can i accommodate
the things that are happening how can i
accommodate this technology into my life
how can i have rules and procedures and
values and virtues that keep me right
around this it's like it's like walking
down the street
like
being someone that
is potentially a heroin addict walking
down the street and having to actively
avoid needles like that's kind of the
situation right that we're in because in
our evolutionary ancestry
it would have been very very useful to
have got more information information
was quite scarce there was maybe 100
people in your tribe
70 of whom were actually [ __ ] useful
and interesting so what we did there's a
guy that was on sam harris's show and he
talked about the fact that we're
information foragers so he says that
we're constantly on the lookout for
information in the same way that a
squirrel forages for food we forage for
information
and typically information would have
been super [ __ ] scarce like if you've
ever spent an amount of time around
people without
any distractions or phone or connection
to the outside world and it's a small
number of people after a while you kind
of unless they're interesting people you
kind of run out of stuff to say and
you're like yeah i
i've heard that that happens to me on
dates that happens to me on dates
some dates end up going on for like
four five six hours yep
just kind of because we don't really
have anything
better to do it's like
if if i end the date i'm going to go
home and get on my phone yep so it's
like we're here we're whatever let's
just keep talking whatever sit here in
silence and stare we just don't have
anything else to talk about yeah so
but what we what we've got now is all of
this information oh that that might be
useful that might help me survive that
might help me reproduce and none of it
does none of it does it's [ __ ]
it's clapped man
but dude black calendar ladies and
gentlemen zacky boy why should people go
if they want to check out your stuff
uh
go to my youtube channel just my name
zach tellender also go on my instagram
coach underscore zt
uh i have a patreon and there you can
find weightlifting programs and general
strength programs for super cheap
what else that's probably it that's it
oh i have a i have a subreddit now
that's sick
yeah [ __ ] so i've got a subreddit
i've got like uh i think like 1500
people on there yeah that's awesome yeah
so if you if you go there too there's a
bunch of in cells talking about
weightlifting no they're good people
they really like them yeah i love it man
cheers
thanks for having me thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that then
press here for a selection of the best
clips from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace